a rally as you see here outside the  southern nevada health district this was  last night members of the culinary union  want the health district to investigate  violations of covet 19 protection  measures  those measures require hotel rooms get  cleaned every day  but union leaders say that's just not  happening  they're not doing what they're supposed  to do and we're here to make them do  that as far as the cleanliness of the  rooms every day and we need to have that  done every day not just every other day  we need it done every day because of the  cobit  the health district says it has not  received any formal complaints from the  culinary union